as the program runs it will be building
up internal data stores for keeping
track of all the variables that are
available to different function objects
and I'm going to picture that stuff over
here on the right this will be a diagram
or a picture of our in-memory system
since each new run of a function is
supposed to operate in complete
isolation from all the previous runs a
new execution context should be created
every time you run a function thus for
each lexical scope there may be many
in-memory scopes created during
execution or there may be none it all
depends on how many times you run a
given function in your code to examine
execution contexts we will need to
actually run this program so let's
simulate that here the yellow arrow will
point to the position in the code where
our simulated interpreter has reached
sort of like a debugger before this
first line of code even runs the
interpreter will start out by setting up
an execution environment for you the
first step will be to create an
in-memory global scope context to hold
all of the global variables so let's
visualize that execution context data
store off to the right here we'll use a
similar color as the lexical scope
region that it relates to here our
interpreter is building up a storage
system for the global scope the yellow
border is around the interpreters
current execution context that is to say
whichever one the interpreter starts its
variable lookups in so far the global
context is the only one that exists so
of course it's the current scope as the
first line of code runs the interpreter
builds up a new key value mapping inside
of the execution context in order to
keep track of the value that is bound to
the name hero the a euro function
randomly generated the value gaol which
will be stored in the hero variable like
the line above it this line implies a
simple assignment operation now the
value being assigned is a function that
spans several lines but the interpreter
is going to ignore all the red and the
blue code for now they will only get run
when the function is actually called so
that line of code has the effect of
adding a new key value pair to our
global scope context